I can't fall back to sleep I don't even
remember what worked me up to begin with
but now that I'm awake I can't fall back
to sleep no matter how hard I try you
wouldn't even be so bad being awake in
the middle of the night if I could just
get up and move but I can't move a
muscle
I can't even wiggle as much as a toll
and trust me it's not for lack of trying
after the initial panic has set in and
passed and I realized that I wasn't dead
I racked my brain and tried to come up
with an explanation for my immobility I
began to remember a lecture about dreams
and sleep disorders in a psychology
course I took freshman year that's what
made me think of sleep paralysis which
might help explain why the only part of
my body I can move on my eyes may be if
I paid more attention in class I'd be
able to figure out how to raise myself
from this state but as it is I'm stuck
here waiting for one of my roommates to
come check on me in the morning it
doesn't make for much of a plan but it's
all I have it certainly helps stop the
growing pangs of fear that was spreading
through my body although in a pit of my
stomach
I still feel uneasy there is an ominous
yet measured beep that I can faintly
hear too soft to be a fire alarm or a
carbon monoxide detector and it's been
going on for long enough that it's
definitely not a car alarm
it feels both close and distant at the
same time like it's by my side but just
out of reach regardless this isn't the
source of my uneasiness no it's
something else keeping me awake
something else stirring in my chest
giving me a sense of dread it's like
something's in the room with me but I
can't quite see it everything looks a
little blurry like things are moving too
fast there are other sounds like the
soft pitter-patter of feet around me and
just outside my room I can hear what
sounds like whispering since I don't
live alone and the walls are pretty thin
this usually wouldn't be a strange
occurrence even this late at night
however these voices aren't familiar
the murmurs those soft somehow sound
urgent what I want to decipher what
they're saying deep down I know that
even this is not what has me on edge
it's something in the air something is
off as I'm trying to pinpoint what is
making me feel so Restless
the sound of shuffling feet faint
whispers and even the incessant beeping
all began to fade away my vision swims
and darkness begins to swirl around me
growing thicker I can feel my chest
tighten and my breath catch I try to cry
out but no sound emits from my mouth not
a scream nor squeak I tried desperately
to move even an inch but my body doesn't
respond it feels as though I'm being
held down by invisible hands and being
smothered by an infinite darkness and a
deafening silence the pangs of fear that
I suppressed before grow and spread
through my body of a burnin fervor the
uneasiness that world in a pit of my
stomach is now a full-blown terror and
just as I'm about to succumb to my fear
and apparent demise a bright light
parts' the sea of darkness and I'm
brought face to face with a woman the
woman's hair is a ghostly white which
reaches out into the infinite darkness
surrounding her like wispy tendrils her
skin is so pale that it's almost
transparent I feel like I could make out
the bones beneath her skin if I strained
my eyes hard enough but it's not her
hair or her skin that has me captivated
its our eyes or lack thereof well her
eyes are supposed to be
instead I just sunk and black sockets
staring at them I feel as if though I'm
being sucked back into a never-ending
black void with some difficulty I
eventually managed to pull my eyes away
from them looking down I notice that
she's wearing a long white dress that
matches her hair the dress was obviously
once beautiful but now it lies in
tatters clinging to her body like a
vines on a gnarled tree I raise my gaze
to meet hers yet again but before I can
even try to utter a word
she raises a withered finger and points
directly at me
her thin lips part and she'd let sallow
moon as her mouth widens the moon begins
to raise in pitch like a cat will come
in to boil her moon rapidly escalates
into an otherworldly whale her mouth has
now become so impossible wide that its
carnivorous I shut my eyes and covered
my ears in a desperate but futile
attempt to block out the piercing sound
it continues Ford feels like an eternity
I feel blood trickle out of my ears and
down my neck even with my eyes closed I
still see her ghostly [ __ ] looking at
me it feels like she's almost looking
through me directly into my soul when I
finally open my eyes it's not to the
oppressing darkness with the female
Specter or even the familiarity of my
room but to what appears to be the
inside of a hospital room I try to move
and I'm immediately jostled by a sharp
pain in my chest a sharp cry passed my
lips and my hand automatically reached
towards my chest I'm not given much time
to reflect my shock as someone strides
into the room at that moment a pale man
with a bald head looks down at me and
smiles sure enough an impressive set of
white teeth he stressed in a white
overcoat and has a black dress shut
peeking out underneath I wouldn't try to
move if I were you trust me I'm a
professional he says with a mischievous
wink as he steps closer I make out a
name on a badge pinned to his lapel it
reads Dantan with two N's I turned my
head and I'm greeted by a very familiar
beeping the heart monitor is connected
to my chest by tubes and wires I can't
quite see there was also an oxygen mask
lying on my head
the doctor seemingly reads my thoughts
and explains that I had quite a rough
night I was wheeled in by the paramedics
last night after I collapsed in my room
one of my roommates had called 9-1-1 you
had a rather close call he finished
still smiling I begin to straighten up
slightly and he hands me a small cup of
water after a few sips I tell him about
my nightmare he smile never fades as I
talk
sounds like you dreamt of a banshee he
says when I finish he begins to explain
when I give him a quizzical look ghastly
specters to let out blood-curdling cries
they're known as harbingers of death his
grin seems to grow wider as he talks and
I feel an uneasiness sprout in my chest
despite their frightening appearance
there merely warnings that death is
around the corner
I begin to cough and reach for my chest
again death does not like to be cheated
you mortals you build structures and
even create professions just to delay
the inevitable an utterly pointless
venture wouldn't you agree
I clutter up my chest and look back at
the small paper cup of liquid and I
realize it's not water
the man's skin begins to fall away and
he reaches a skeletal finger to pluck
out one of his eyes he removes his white
coat letting it fall to the floor
and pulls up the hood of a black robe
he's wearing the creature looms over me
and gently closes the lids of my eyes I
sincerely hope that your next dream is a
bit more pleasant
[Music]